as Europe city's empty the homeless are
no longer invisible but they are a risk
of being forgotten everybody is very
scared everybody doesn't want to help
everybody
these calluses powers they're on the
streets for many reasons abuse addiction
mental illness they're already 20 times
more likely to contract tuberculosis or
other lung diseases and now there's the
corona virus but it's hunger that brings
them here to a charity handing out food
since the lockdown help has been in
short supply there's a lot less food
because their restaurants are shut
hotels are shut these these people that
you contribute to us normally a dead
give us food surplus food these are
extreme situations these are very
dangerous times even before this
pandemic struck the number of people
sleeping rough has been going up in
nearly every single country in Europe
now an estimated 700,000 people are
sleeping on the streets across the
continent up 70% in the past decade 300
rooms in London hotels owned by the
Intercontinental Group have been booked
for the next two months to help homeless
people self isolate but there are
thousands more in need in Spain the Army
and Red Cross have set up temporary
shelters with hundreds of beds and here
in the French town of Khan the Film
Festival venue has opened its doors to
the destitute but these are only
temporary solutions that aid workers
fear could worsen the spread I think we
have to be really careful that we don't
come up with solutions that actually
make things worse so grouping homeless
people together in unsafe settings
without triage is going to create
massive clusters for infection already
seen ground
in the Italian city of Naples locals
have been filling baskets with food and
lowering them from their balconies those
who can are asked to put food in those
who can't afford to eat are encouraged
to help themselves
Bart Italian police have handed out
fines to some homeless people for
breaking curfews despite many shelters
cutting capacity or closing altogether
across Europe aid workers are urging
authorities to show leniency how can you
stay at home they ask when you don't
have one neve barker al jazeera london